let's not think about what it means to
add and subtract complex numbers so
let's say I have a complex number a and
it let's say that it's equal to 3 3 plus
2i and let's say I have complex number B
that is equal to negative 1 minus 3
minus 3i let's think about what it means
to add a and B so let's say I have a
third complex number that is C that is
defined as a plus B so I encourage you
to pause this video and think about it
on your own what a plus B is going to be
well what we could do is well this is
just going to be equal to this is going
to be equal to 3 plus 2i that's a 3 plus
2i plus B which is so plus negative 1
negative 1 minus 3i we could write it
like that if we want to really be clear
what B is and what a is just like that
now how would we actually add these two
together well we can't add a real part
to a complex part that's why this is
about as simplified or we can't add a
real part to an imaginary part I should
say that's why this is about as
simplified as you can get but I can add
real part to real part and imaginary
part to imaginary part so I could add
the 3 to the negative 1 to get 3 plus
negative 1 is 2 so I get a real part now
of 2 and then I can add the two the two
imaginary parts so if I have if I have 2
I minus 3i 2 I minus 3i that's going to
be negative 1 I or I could say that's
going to be negative I so just like that
I added the two real parts added the two
imaginary parts and I got 2 minus I and
we could also visualize this on the
complex plane we could do that using an
Argand diagram in an Argand diagram we
represent each of these each of these
complex numbers as vectors on the
complex plane so that's our imaginary
axis and this is our real axis
this is our real axis and a is 3 plus 2i
so 1 2 3 along the real axis and then 2
along the imaginary axis imaginary part
is to 2i so 3 plus 2i gets us right over
there and I'm going to represent that as
a vector as a vector where its tail is
at the origin and its head is that is
that the coordinates 3 and the real on
the real axis 2 on the imaginary axis so
that right there on my Argand diagram
argh and diagram is my representation of
vector a now let's do the same thing for
vector B it is negative 1 along the real
axis and negative 3 along the imaginary
I along the imaginary axis 1 2 3 so it
sticks us right over there if we draw if
we represented it as a vector vector or
complex number B could be visualized
this way and now when we add a plus B
you could add them the exact same way
that you would add vectors you take the
tail of B or you can you essentially
shift B over so you take the tail of B
and you put it at the head of a but it's
the same thing so when you go down 3 and
you go to the left 1 so you go down 3
and you go to the left 1 so it's gonna
put you right over here so all I've done
is I've shifted B over to this part so
that its tail is at the head of a so it
goes right over there so this is vector
B or not vector this is complex number B
so this is B right over here and notice
now if we start at the tail of a and we
go to the head of this shifted B this
right over here is going to be vector C
this is going to be a plus B so this
vector right over here C notice C is 2
minus I 2 real part negative 1 imaginary
part this right over here is C which is
a plus B so you were able to add these
two complex numbers you could visualize
adding them the same way that you would
visualize adding 2 when we added two
vectors and the true and traditional and
in the traditional coordinate plane and
it makes complete sense because
is when you're adding these complex
numbers you're keeping the real part
separate and these are essentially the
horizontal components of the vector and
you're keeping the imaginary part
separate and that's essentially the
vertical parts of these vectors